the Chinese city of Wuhan is on lockdown
getting anywhere fast here is impossible
so while a flight is ready to take
stranded Britons home
the question is whether they'll get to
the airport on time this is a complete
transport pattern in the city I've told
I've said this to them every time I've
spoken to them and asked them what they
can do to help and every time always
make your own way that so if I've really
heard that one person can actually get
to the airport and the rest of
struggling even just taking the flight
itself could be a risk you know it only
takes one person to be infected on the
fly and then you've got if if the whole
if everybody that can make the flight
gets on it you've got 200 people that
are infected so risk worth taking that
moment
probably not he's understood the plane
bringing the Britons back will land the
Air Force Station Brize Norton in West
Oxfordshire and then those on board will
be taken to an NHS facility on the we're
all in northwest England sky knees
understands they'll be quarantined here
at arrow Park hospital for 14 days it's
close to a specialist Center equipped to
deal with a potential outbreak it's
still unclear exactly what's going to
happen with the people returning to the
UK to be quarantined we've asked the
Department of Health inside here for
more information but despite our
requests they've told us that health
secretary is not available for comment
but a former health secretary was and
told Sky News evacuation plan
potentially has serious risks one brings
together people on a plane increases the
chance of their transmitting the
infection from one to another then
brings them to United Kingdom and they
you have and and the transmission starts
from there moving any group of people
from a place where there is inflation to
one where there isn't it's not on the
face of it a public health measure it's
essentially this is a in effect for the
families of the British citizens in
Wuhan this is essentially a humanitarian
mission
as Britain's return from Wuhan there is
concern of how the NHS struggling under
winter pressures will cope if cases rise
there's bigger questions about whether
the NHS at this time of immense strain
this winter has the capacity the
capacity to deal with it but for now the
priority is getting those people home
and making sure they get the care they
need the UK is a country already on high
alert a man staying at this hotel in
York was taken ill on Wednesday is being
tested for coronavirus so far public
health England have confirmed a hundred
and sixty-one such tests have been
carried out all have been negative but
that is likely to change and the NHS is
taking robust measures to ensure any
cases of the virus are contained
quarantine II more than a hundred people
is a mammoth task not seen in modern
times
Charlotte Lomas Sky News